this episode of fun science is brought
to you by brilliant fake it till you
make it the idea that if you want to be
say a happier or more confident person
all you have to do is pretend to be
those things and you'll become them sure
it might sound like an unscientific
modern idea but it actually dates all
the way back to the ancient Greek
philosopher Aristotle he believed you
should act as if the idea that if you
want to be a more virtuous person you
should act as a virtuous person would
you need to pee so bad but I need to go
and teach a class but wait if I simply
act as if I don't need to be then I
won't have to that's good that down I am
very smart
now obviously you can't fake your way
through everything but sometimes the
line between believing and actually
being is quite as clear as it might seem
in this episode of it's fun yeah have
you ever heard the idea that if you want
to feel happier all you need to do is
smile go on try it well how do you feel
like an idiot of course you do
however though you might feel dumb at
first it's actually been shown that
forcing a smile can decrease your stress
levels and cause you to have a more
positive reaction to others in one study
people were asked to either force a
smile or force a frown and were then
shown the same photos of people and
asked how they felt about them so what's
going on well as it turns out our brain
triggers emotions based on the physical
sensations in our body so you might
think that when you feel nervous your
body shakes but actually your brain
notices your body shaking and then
activates your fear emotion weird right
so if we're feeling down and then we
force a smile our brain notices this
physical action and then activates your
happy emotion
I guess I feel a bit better however it's
always better to have a genuine reason
to smile there's a muscle in your face
your opq laris oculi which only
contracts during a real smile
and it's this authentic smiling
experience which will make you happiest
overall but what if you want to feel
more confident can you fake fat well
some studies have shown that people who
adopted inexpensive power pose similar
to how an athlete stands after winning a
race reported feeling more powerful but
though the science behind this is still
up for debate but what if faking it
could trick you into performing better
at specific tasks ever heard of the
phrase dress for the job you want well
in one study participants were given a
lab coat to wear an outfit generally
associated with attentiveness and
carefulness and were asked to complete
an attention related task compared to
another group who were given the same
task the who were told the outfit was a
painter's coat those who wore the lab
coat performed better at the test and
finished I did an art so next time you
find yourself in a bad mood or in need
of a confidence boost why not try faking
it science shows us that sometimes
Liberty can help but remember you can't
fake your way through everything let's
just act as if that didn't happen and
speaking of things that you can't fake
when it comes to learning the best way
to gain knowledge is by doing and if you
want to learn more science by doing you
should check out brilliant the way that
brilliant works is that it gives you
active problems to solve which is a
great way to reinforce the information
you might have learnt from more passive
learning tools like well like episodes
of fun science brilliant has a big
selection of different science courses
to try out but if you don't know where
to start
I'd recommend their science essentials
course as a fun way to get back to grips
with the basics to learn more go to
brilliant org ford smash fun science and
sign up for free although the first 200
people who go to that link will also get
20% off an annual premium subscription
and that is all for this round of fun
science videos I really hoped you liked
them and I guess I'll see you when I see
you
thanks a bunch bye-bye